[Music]
i am very emotional when it comes to my
phones i can't see someone drop my phone
i can't see someone scratch it these are
my babies
[Music]
this is jayesh kali and he's got a
pretty peculiar collection
for years jayesh has been growing a
massive collection of various cell
phones one two three four five six seven
eight
how many phones exactly today i have
counted all the phones and those are
2371
so it's been five to six years i've
started collecting this phone i've
collected cell phones from all around
the world from you know europe uk us
switzerland
dubai a lot of countries my wife
is very
angry on me because i've used all her
wardrobes all my phones are in the
bedroom
most of them in the cars in cupboards
everywhere in the house
[Music]
hello
jayesh's obsession for these phones
began with his very first nokia 3310
what could have been an unfortunate
incident proved to him the phone's
durability i was on a phone a friend of
mine pushed me and my phone fell down
from the second floor of the corridor in
the college i went down running i was
pretty tense will it work will it not i
put back the battery and the phone was
surprisingly working and that's where my
love began for nokia these aren't just
relics of a bygone era jaish has some
pretty strict criteria for adding a new
phone to his collection so whenever i
buy cell phones i keep a couple of
things into consideration one is it
needs to be in mint condition
second it needs to be in complete
working condition because you know you
don't just buy them for collecting you
need to own them you need to use them
yeah yeah you heard the right time the
nokia collector tell me my friends and
family
have a mix of opinions some say
this is a very crazy guy
some feel proud and some saiyans have
put in so much of money in a dead
investment but they really don't know
the fact it's the other way around
while jayesh's collection has been
recognized as the largest of its kind in
india
he's got his eyes on a bigger prize i am
going to attempt for the guinness world
record i am already known as a nokia
cellphone man in india i know the
goldinger guinness book of world records
adds a prestigiousness to you and your
personality
for jayesh it's about more than just
records or recognition i take care of
them a lot and i stare at them i look at
them and i feel happy from inside
[Music]